what up guys what up welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my new show which I call live
streaming when Pearl feels like
it until I get
remonetized you know as you guys know I
have been taking some time off and in
this time off I I've decided I need low
stress you know in the last two years
have dealt with a lot of stress a lot of
hate
videos lot you know just a lot of also a
lot of great times a lot of amazing
times thanks to all of you okay but for
the time being I'm kind of gonna have a
sporadic streaming schedule that's just
going to happen when I feel inspired so
if you guys have a problem with that put
a two in the chat if you don't have a
problem with that one in the chat I'm
sorry I'm sorry this is just how it's
going to be right now now okay uh I'm
sure at some point I'll get back to it
probably around the 12th of February but
you know so before I start I do have a
whole topic that we're going to talk
about today I'm going to get to it but I
wanted to go through some announcements
so first of all we have a new page
called The Audacity talent
show so what is the audacity talent show
basically people that we consider I know
you guys are putting ones and twos I
don't care I'm gonna do what I want
anyway sorry guys look there's no you
could put all the twos ones in the chat
I'm doing what I do okay so I thought
it'd be interesting before we sign
talent to like test them so basically
we're going to post people on the
audacity Network talent show blessing
please put it in the
chat um
and yeah you guys if you guys like some
of the talents that apply like the video
subscribe and then we'll consider
putting on a show for him and if you're
interested you know feel free you got to
be in London please stop messaging me
from other states countries whatever um
so that's one announcement second
announcement because a lot of people
have been asking Pearl are you in
Chicago are you in London like what are
you doing where are you going okay great
question well I've been going back and
forth for the time
being and we're building a studio in
Chicago so what I'd like to do is I'd
like to get a bunch of one-on-one
interviews in Chicago I want to do them
in
person and so if there's any guests like
I'd like to get Jesse Lee Peterson on
I'd like to get Alex Jones on in person
they've both been on but I think it'd be
awesome to you know do like a Joe Rogan
style one-on-one interview with them so
we're building a studio in Chicago now I
got really lucky you know my dad's
helping me out we can also you know have
them play
basketball in order to get on I'll be
like you have to shoot a free throw or
something um yeah and so now we have
three talents here we have Nazarene
behind the curtain with nazarine right
now she's doing reaction videos but
she's GNA be doing some original content
this month I think she's really good at
Street interviews so I think we're going
to give her a go with that you know
Christine her debunking the lunacy
series um yeah so the talent show is in
the chat in the chat okay yeah so we got
a lot of stuff going
on okay so what I wanted to talk about
and the reason I titled this so what
happens now it actually has nothing to
do with
me I get I get kind of nervous for these
live shows it's so weird I used to go
live all the time I'm getting kind of
nervous I don't know why but it's okay
okay so I got a lot of heat this week
okay
and the reason I got a lot of heat was
because I
basically I they they said I came for
the tradcons the Christians and a lot of
people took this as me attacking
God and I'd like to clarify I think that
traditional relationships are good I
believe in God I think God is good I'm a
Catholic I know a lot of Christians say
I'm not Catholic enough I I don't know
you know
but um and it's so weird I'm like what
do you follow me to church who are you
anyways anyways um but sometimes when I
put in my observations about the church
I've noticed that people react to me
okay I got to log into my Twitter one
second people react to me very similarly
to the way they react to say
um to say
when I talk about women so like if I say
the church has been
feminized and feminism is rampant in the
church if I say there's no difference
between Church women and normal
women people will react the same way
they react to women they'll say not all
women are like that they'll say not all
churches are like that then they'll say
like oh well what women do you
know the same way they'll say well what
churches do you know so again when I
look at stuff guys it's never I'm never
trying to inject my morality onto
something so when I have like a take on
something I'm looking at what I believe
to be true not what I want to be true
and I want you to understand the
distinction so when I look
at religion like let's say the Catholic
church right they just said in the
Catholic Church they're now ordaining
like they're blessing same-sex couples
um and I'm Catholic this is not what I
would like to be
true but if I'm being honest the truth
is it seems like all the churches are
headed in a more liberal
Direction this isn't what I want this
isn't what I hope this is just what's
true and I want to tell you guys a
couple more things that I believe to be
true and I want to to explain why I have
these opinions
so I believe that women are women
regardless of where you find
them I think that women have a certain
nature okay and it seems like the more
freedom we
get the more we tend to go for 20% of
men I don't really find this to be
different in Christian churches Lutheran
churches and I'm in London
okay and a lot of the problems that we
complain about in the
west I have found that truly people from
other countries have the same
complaints so you know there's this
whole passport Bros thing and I will say
the girls in other countries are a bit
more feminine they're in better shape
sure that's probably the number one
thing but I still believe that women are
women and women are always just going to
go for the top roughly 20% of
men
okay I believe that when women are given
choice and you've seen in the last
hundred years women can do whatever we
want we have been given more and more
choice to do whatever the heck we
want you will see more women pick single
motherhood again this is not what I
think is correct this is not what I
think is right this is not what I think
is moral this is just what I think is
true I I don't think that you go into
these religious
communities and you find these girls
that have a different nature that are
different like again women are women and
part of this I came to this conclusion
partially because you know I had um a
family of cousins okay and this C they
were um traditional Catholics so they
went to a Latin mass and I'd like to say
there I have more anecdotal stories but
this is just
one and you know they had six kids and
they were raised in a going to Latin
Mass every
Sunday Latin Mass
okay they the dad really like he would
throw away clo he wouldn't let us watch
PG-13 movies I remember I went there for
New Year's every year and I would think
I would get so annoyed I'm like I can't
watch a PG-13 movie when I was like
15 and I remember being so irritated but
the older I get I I understood why they
did it you know this is an uncle of mine
he's the only one that agrees with me
that women shouldn't vote and it was so
funny because when I was younger I
thought he was crazy and then I got
older I'm like oh my gosh he's right
he's right he's right so but his kids
didn't all turn out
Catholic and they did everything right I
don't know they homeschooled their
children they they protected their kids
from the world but he's still you
know you can't completely Shield your
children from the culture okay and what
I've realized is that you know I know
people from single mother homes that
just were never there were girls they
just weren't promiscuous or divorced
parents they just were never like
that and you know I I know girls that
came from that were pastor's daughters
and we're absolute
[__] and what you realize is women we
have our own agency every woman you know
picks for herself
okay I don't really buy this you know I
do think women are
stupid like I do think we're Dumber for
sure we're less logical but you know
women make different choices and women
come from a variety of backgrounds you
know I know girls that went to the bars
every weekend and didn't do I mean it's
more probable right but again like none
of this is a fail safe okay I just think
women are women regardless of where you
go okay so when women are given choice
they choose single motherhood when women
are given choice there's less
children now you know I've talked to
historians about this there's a guy he's
um really really smart guy his name is
David Baker and he says women have been
killing their kids from prehistoric
times I mean because in the caveman days
right you know they they would have two
children
and if they had a third it would slow
down the whole pack so what what they
have to do the women just had to kill
their kids you know and I heard in the
1800s as well you know it wouldn't get
recorded a lot but in the first year
wasn't uncommon for women to kill
abortion is not
new women are evil I don't know what to
tell you sorry guys sorry guys um so I
just think that's women's
nature not all women some women do it
more some less but I think when you give
a hundred women a choice doesn't matter
if they're Christian Catholic Muslim
whatever more are going to pick
that sorry um promiscuity you know 90
when women are given the choice in the
last 100 years when we got the choice to
sleep around birth control came what did
we
choose 95% of women have had premarital
sex H and the majority of women prefer
premarital
sex they say this this is like
self-reported okay
so you know I I don't say this to be
mean to women I just don't know how I
can like look at the facts and say I
mean this is just kind of you know what
women pick again this is why this is my
opinion I think women are more sexual
than men but that's that's a different
day
um okay that's Elliot why did you say
that in the chat were you R worded by
your uncle no what are you are you
weirdos okay someone said have you ever
felt the urge to punch a 304 I plead the
fifth
I pleaded the fifth all
right don't don't make me okay okay so
next am I only talking about American
women no no guys I have the most
International experience
ever I don't care what anyone says I
grew up with nannies from around the
world every year we would get a new
nanny okay and they'll say Pearl's so
privileged yeah okay every year I had
nine siblings every year we would get a
nanny from a different country I had
nannies from South Africa
Russia Germany
everywhere women are women like um I'll
give you an example one Nanny we found
out was on a campsite in our
house one Nanny one
Nanny married my
cousin and divorced his
ass another one married my uncle but
they're still together they're they're
actually a cute couple but I mean
again women are women you know and even
growing up I would hear stories of
nannies in the neighborhoods like the
nannies would tell me stories about
other nannies a bunch of them would
sleep with the
husbands did I have a black nanny I mean
yeah I mean I one or two yeah all over
Russia South Africa Brazil Germany I
think yeah okay Germany was the most
common one but okay
so abortion isn't new sex work you
know and there's a bit of discrepancy
between these stats
but five to 15 I think it's closer to
20% if you include sugar babying and all
that stuff of women are doing sex
work again that only happens in America
no
guys because and then on top of that I
lived in Germany for three months I've
been to
Japan I I live in London which is the
most International
City women are
women there's better women there's worse
women but women are women okay so this
is current marriage based
on different data sources this is
current ma marriage okay women sleep
around in their early to mid 20s and by
sleep around this could mean multiple
long-term
relationships this could mean hookups
this could mean only fans it's different
for each
chick but most women aren't getting
married and they're not virgins
okay all right so the average marriage
is around
30 and generally it takes about 3 years
to get a guy to marry you and 3 months
of casually dating until it's official
the average marriage lasts about eight
years okay so this is this is
marriage and the disagreement I get into
with tradcons I'm sorry
guys I'm sorry I gotta come for you
again I do and I want you guys
to I want you guys
to understand where I'm coming
from you know there's this movement to
take the Christ
pill and I don't think that's a bad
movement but I don't think it will work
okay and I want to list things that I
don't think will work to get the average
age of first marriage lower oh I forgot
to have the birth rate in here it's like
two um these things I don't think will
be effective in getting the birth rate
lower in returning to traditionalism any
form of that I I just don't see working
okay tweeting take the Christ pill this
sounds nice this will get you likes and
followers I don't see that to be
effective telling women to not sleep
around with the best guy they can I mean
women have all always shared men
historically 80% of women reproduced 40%
of men
reproduced so you're gonna say women
women women stop being the way you've
always
been I if I had to put money on it if I
had to guess I don't think that's G to
work now I love to be proven wrong so go
ahead prove me wrong but but if I had to
guess telling the Leonardo DiCaprio of
the world to stop sleeping with 22y
[Music]
old okay now Leonardo dicapri someone
say their Nanny gave them an
STD all right got you gotta chill out
chill out all right okay so telling now
Leonardo DiCaprio is just an example of
a guy that doesn't give an f and only
dates women under 25 there's men like
this in every town
okay I I just don't I don't see that
working I don't think if you say to
Leonardo
DiCaprio please stop sleeping with these
hot women he's gonna say oh let me just
do
it okay now this one this
one hurts me a little little
bit this one hurts me to say okay this
hurts hurts my soul a little bit I I I
question if returning our rights is ever
going to
happen you know
um I I don't know if that's going to
happen in my lifetime I don't think
we're GNA see as much as I would like it
to happen if I'm being honest with
myself
I don't really see the vote going away I
don't really see abortion going away and
a lot of people will come at me and
they'll say pearl Pearl Pearl
Pearl aren't you just giving
up I mean I'm just a streamer what am I
supposed to do about it anyways okay
okay breeding them out so I looked up
the average number of kids that
religious PE or Christians have it's
like
2.7 I I I've seen maybe like 0 five like
Christian people have 0 five more
children than non-Christian
people is that really gonna breed them
out oh sorry they say breed them out as
in we'll have more kids than them so the
future will be conserv
it
I like the idea you know but I I just
don't think that's going to happen
because and I'll tell you why this is a
little anecdotal so take it or leave it
but again you know one of my my my the
homeschooled family that I was telling
you guys about one of their kids joined
a
thruple I mean what more did this is
this Dad supposed to do they
homeschooled their children they didn't
even have cell phones till they were
like
16 one of his kids joined a thruple he
like moved to Oregon and just went super
li like I mean we we have Preachers
Daughters like why is that a
connotation just because you're
conservative it doesn't mean your kids
will grow up to make conservative
decisions
uh okay so I don't think
saying submit to feminism
or saying sorry I don't think saying
don't submit to feminism is going to
work okay
I I'm sorry I just I don't think being
on your phone and tweeting please don't
submit to feminism is is an effective
strategy I'm open to it I'll listen to
you guys but because I want you to think
of yourself and many of you are just
normal men in this country right I mean
let's say you're a trucker that lives in
Ohio your name's
Bob what are you supposed to do I mean
you can't change the entire
political
system unless you want to get into
politics which I don't recommend all
right which I
mean
like do I even let's use Tate as an
example I I'm a fan of Tate I enjoy Tate
stuff okay Andrew
Tate do I think that his impact is going
to decrease the number of only fans
models in 10
years no I'm sorry I think there's
certain individuals he's going to
inspire the same way Kevin Samuels did
and I think that's great I got nothing
against them but if I if I had to say
across the
board I I wouldn't bet on it is that
fair put a one in the chat if that's
fair put a two in the chat if that's
unfair okay truck driving a ho in every
town all right guys I
don't I don't know okay all right so you
know Banning
things again you know I I and I say you
know I'd love to ban women voting
and divorce
I would I bet on it happening in the
next 10
years no I I'm sorry
no okay so these are the things that I
don't think will work okay
so now when I first got into the red
pill space you know my actual first
thought was I didn't know why men didn't
didn't want to get
married this was a little bit foreign to
me because most people in my family were
married if they did divorce people got
remarried in like you know extended
family whatever marriage was kind of the
norm
so you know when I first got into the
red pill space this this was a confusion
to me and I want to show you guys
how I changed my
mind I started interviewing guys about
their divorce experience I'm G to show
you guys one now this is a guy who had a
woman turn his whole entire family
against him he had two kids he hasn't
seen I think it was two I forget
sometimes I get the guys confused he
basically gets married right he he wants
to I mean does he look like an evil
monster to
you does he look like this
evil awful
guy and you can you could be the judge
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe he's just lying
you know and this is him talking about
his
experience um getting married and
divorced okay yeah Bob the trucker let's
call him you to see their your son they
every time I ask them that I need you to
support me here I stop communication
with the ex mhm cuz obviously that plays
into her Court M they all said no we're
going to cont continue contacting her CU
then she what she was doing she was
carrying on communication with my family
and I go she said this so so she
alienated him from him his entire
family his entire family because she
told his entire family he was an abuser
all the stuff about she saying this for
I don't
know um so what would she tell your
family would she say that you abused her
yes so I was abusive and all the same
thing I was financially abusive um oh so
she basically started brainwashing your
family that's the best way of explaining
it yes you into thinking that and like
because she's a woman wait did you guys
say the volume the volume needs to go up
okay okay I think it's this which one is
it blessing
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna test one I
think it might be this no that's not it
okay this one I'm to try it like kind of
crying wolf in a way is this better and
um your mother your sister your father
and your cousins okay
and um and then basically she would use
them to get you to break the order yeah
so like she would make it so you didn't
see your son through okay the volume's
low
how do I okay I gotta remember which one
this
is okay let me let me text blessing
sorry you expected this all right all
right
um wait which one is it I'm
sorry
four your family because she made your
mother the primary oh it's there like
car like person okay I'm sorry guys
we're g to start it over
okay but basically guys I would do
interview after interview after
interview it would be the same stories
and I'm I'm gonna show you okay
sorry on the
keyboard
okay the volume's on here that plays
into her court now can you hear they all
said no we're going to continue
contacting her because then she she was
doing this look was great on me I served
I served in Orange sorry sorry she was
carrying on communication with my family
and I go she said this what are she
saying this for I don't
know um so what would she tell your
family would she say that you abused her
yes so I was abusive and all the same
thing I was financially abusive um oh so
she basically started brainwashing your
family that's the best way of explain it
yes thinking that and like because she's
a woman basically she she was like kind
of crying wolf in a way exactly and um
your mother your sister your father and
your cousins okay
and um and then basically she would use
them to get you to break the order yeah
so like she would make it so you didn't
see your son through your family because
she made your mother the
primary like care like person so your
mom had to pick up your son and she was
speaking to your mom and making it so
and then she could go to court and say
you broke the order correct it was it
was my mother who broke the order if you
imagine if that now happens that shows a
dysfunctional
family
oh okay and that's the route she was
going there so then you go to the second
court date and what happens um
uh she then said to me so on the first
few all right you guys are saying it's
too loud
now um let me turn it down a
four okay let me
put um days I had with my son weekends
one weekend asked for can you bring some
toys with him cuz I had seen him for
five months I didn't know his toy taste
had changed you know I asked for clothes
I asked for Wellies well Welly boots and
asked him for a jacket she put that
against me in the courtroom said to me
that was demanding
Behavior wow that's the worst she could
put against me at that that point
demanding Behavior demanding Behavior
okay and I had to discuss to the court
so out of those three obviously the
court Judiciary System has to go has to
choose a topic I had to explain to the
court why I asked for toys to accompany
my
son um which was I just wanted to
support him I didn't know the toys I had
were now too young for him um I wanted
to be able to know roughly what his
tastes were make it comfortable for him
and then I'd be able to get toys on us
afterwards you know um in fact I didn't
even know what his nappy size was I
didn't know what his clothes size was
when I picked him up it was just
literally in his clothes in his jacket
and a toy in his hand and that was it
mhm and he was two and a half then uh
yes it would have been two and a half
years okay so then what did the court
what did the court tell you so the court
asked me to explain why I asked for toys
mhm so I went into why explain why I
asked for
toys
um uh and then they said
um due to the breakages in the course
order um due to the disagreements going
on um they only gave me then once a
fortnite and that was it now what I had
once every other week they you I also
had to go in so this guy wants to be a
traditional involved
father this woman turned his entire
family against him he gets to see his
son twice a
month guys this is not uncommon I'm
Gonna Keep Going hold on the advice was
to go in to ask for that as well because
otherwise I could get nothing because of
because leading up to the so it was a
Christmas
period um I was supposed to see him
Christmas Day it all broke down the
night
before um and then my mother started to
try and reduce the amount of contact I
was getting um she she canceled all
contact which obviously played into my
ex's hands and I didn't see my son for
another two and a half months so you saw
him once at two when he was 2 and a half
years old and then you didn't see him I
saw him for about 8 to nine
weeks okay and then CU it was like four
month and mind you this costs men like
20 grand a lot of the time I think
that's the average cost 20 grand to get
to see their son every other
week this is
hell this is hell to men okay and if you
guys pull up this playlist called the
sitdown you'll see some of the other
interviews I've done like I I don't want
to just because it's kind of long this
guy
um he the government took his teenage
daughters
away um I I think it was this
one I mean he told me he was on the
verge of suicide
um there there was another guy who I
think it was him he his kids
lived a mile from him and he hadn't seen
them in two years and so you know I
would just list listen to like story
after story after story after
Story Volume my volume's
low can you guys hear me okay
well and you know it's like guys I I
can't ignore this
stuff I mean even let's say there's a
10% chance this happened to you
which I mean divorce is 50% it's not 10
but let's say it's
10 I mean would you sign up for a 10%
chance they destroy your entire
reputation steal your
children take half of your assets uh one
of the guys I interviewed was literally
homeless because he couldn't afford
child support because he lost his job
because of the stress of
everything
okay
so things okay so do I want to go with
things that I think okay
so if you're a trucker I want I want us
to like put us in the the mind of a
trucker in Missouri making
$55,000 a year and he thinks I want a
wife and kids I want to do the
traditionalism thing how does he get
there and guys this is just my point of
view you can take it or leave
it the women are the ones begging for
the premarital sex okay one the majority
of women that's what they want okay but
he says I I want a wife and kids is it
probable for him to wait for a virgin
chick I would argue
no and women women typically want a guy
and I'm not saying this is what guys
should do or shouldn't do I'm I'm trying
to
explain I'm trying to explain why men
get to this conclusion from my from my
point of view okay women want a guy with
more
experience
okay and he doesn't want to get you know
how is he supposed to know the
difference between a good woman and a
bad
woman the only way he could do that is
to get experience with
women so I don't really blame men for
choosing to sleep around I'm not saying
they should I'm not saying it's good
okay I'm saying I don't really blame
them if they get to that
conclusion
okay
um
is it a good idea for a guy to wait for
a non virgin does that really make
sense is it a good idea for a guy to
have no experience with women and sign
up for a
contract that could take away his
reputation his
children and
his like everything really from a guy
now I again I'm not saying what he
should do but I can kind of understand
you
know why men get to that conclusion the
other thing I was thinking about too is
that you know even if you have
kids you know because a lot of times
what I'll hear is that men need to have
children for their legacy
right there is no guarantee that your
kids will even like
you and there have been okay so let me
and by the way this isn't me being a
Doomer guys I started off with the same
mindset as the tradcons I said why are
men afraid of marriage I said I don't
really understand why they don't want to
get married that was my
start and now after learning about it a
bit more I don't know why a guy would
get married
ever okay so
this this is a young
woman who was alienated from her
father now she figured it out but a lot
of women don't have to I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you money and
custody some of my first memories of my
childhood were of my mother telling me
that my father didn't love me I felt
closest to my mom when we were talking
crap about my dad if I rejected my dad I
felt like I was getting my M question do
I really know this person are they
actually who my alienator said they were
I had this overwhelming sense of having
to protect my mom in her mind she truly
believes everything she's saying that my
dad was a terrible person all the time
but just think about how how sick it is
that the parent teaches the child to
hate and then enjoys watching them hate
I did start asking questions and I did
want to fact
check making splashes and
I'm going to try not to get
emotional or angry in this video I'm
going to try to just keep it real with
everybody but I'm really disturbed by
this as I've met other child survivors
we often joke and targeted parents we
often joke that maybe all these
alienators have a Playbook because they
do so many of the same strategies and
alienating behaviors and
patterns and yesterday I was on Tik
Tok when somebody kind of told me
essentially they do have a Playbook but
before I get into that I need to back up
to my
[Applause]
story as I've processed everything this
year I've been able to understand more
and more like what caused the alienation
to solidify the end my parents marriage
was terrible for a long
time and the alienation started at the
end of their marriage but there
was there was a specific event that
really did put the final nail in the
coffin I was 9 years old and I was in my
grandma's car driving back to my
house my grandma is my mom's mom and
when we pulled up to our house there
were five or six cop cars everywhere I
saw my dad with some cops my mom with
some
cops my grandma went hysterical started
crying my stomach dropped I started
crying she turned the car around and
drove me back to her
house I would never set foot in that
house our house
again and later that night I would get
the I would get the um the events what
happened and told to me through my mom
and my grandma allegations of physical
abuse so in my little 9-year-old brain
that was it how can my dad do such a
thing solidified alienation for me and
then I would refuse to talk to him Mery
and for a long time after
that whereas it's ironic because my
brothers who were actually there for
this situation never were alienated from
my dad there were a lot of things I was
not aware of at the time that I have
figured out
now I know there are two sides to every
story but what I remember is a
9-year-old was the next
day being brought to a new school in the
middle of the Year walking to that
School third grade terrified my mom
telling the principal there's a
restraining order against her dad if she
shows up at the school you need to call
the police if he shows up at the school
to get her he she said the same thing to
my teacher as she walked me into the
room I stayed right by my teacher side
the whole day I remember just
looking looking constantly out at the
windows for cop
cars and as this little kid you know I
was really scared that was a really
scary day for me and looking back
now I I don't know what my mom was
thinking but what happened from that
point on is I told you my grandma turned
the car around and drove me back to her
house well that night and for for months
afterwards my
mom me and my four younger brothers we
all stayed at my grandma's house we
never returned to the other house and I
didn't see my dad for a long
time there was a criminal charge filed
against my
dad which was later dropped and all of
this
surely solidified the the the fact that
my dad was a monster abusive and didn't
love me like my mom made me
believe last year I figured out the
other side of the
story not for my dad by the way he okay
how old do you guys think she is
29 she just figured out her dad wasn't
an
abuser how many kids never figure it
out okay let me just still will not say
anything mean or paint my mom in a
negative light so I had to go to other
extended family members to tease out the
truth of the situation to piece my own
life together that's part of the problem
of all this psychological abuse is that
no one tells the child the
truth what I learned last year is this
is what happened you know several
sources said the same thing so I take it
to be
true my parents have been fighting about
several issues for a long time but the
main one was religion my mom was adamant
about wanting to put me in Catholic
School my
dad didn't want me to do that he didn't
want to take me out of school again put
me in a new school I had a lot of
friends in my Charter School I loved it
there they fought over other things too
of course their marriage was terrible he
doesn't deny that she brought out the
worst in him she brought out the worst
of me
well he came
home that
day and at the time in North Carolina 20
years ago all you had to do was claim a
threat of violence in order to have a
restraining order filed and he got home
to the house where he's expecting to see
all of the kids and my mom and there was
a restraining order
there a bogus restraining order
and he got really mad and they
fought but the the way my mom
characterized the fight was completely
blown out of proportion of course he was
mad upon seeing like a bogus restraining
order like any parent would be but there
was no physical abuse um the way it was
characterized to me is not how things
actually went
down needless to say my mom did call the
cops that day
my dad did have to follow the
restraining
order so he couldn't communicate with us
or explain you know I'm still here I
still love you or anything and because
of all these events my dad was advised
by his lawyer to not even try don't even
try to go to
court you'll lose you'll lose tons of
money so he didn't even try to go to
court because all these charges had
already been
filed um in fact what ended up happening
is
that my
mom got a big settlement in the divorce
and an exorbitant amount in child
support every year so much so that we
could live in a really nice house
without her having to work at
all she also got primary custody my dad
got every Wednesday night and every
other weekend and that's hard to be an
active parent having that little time I
also learned last
year
that what I thought was a situation an
event of domestic violence on the part
of my dad my whole life was
actually
contrived by my mom and her
lawyer that's right my mom's lawyer
advised her to get a bogus restraining
order to set up a situation where my dad
would be enraged make claims of abuse to
get a um so I keep hearing that this is
just oneoff instances Pearl's just a
Doomer this doesn't happen but the kids
are growing
up and they're talking guys domestic
violence charge so that she could get
more money from child support and more
custody now that part when I heard it
seemed a little bit evil like demented
last year and that brings me to
yesterday when I was on Tik Tok so I was
on Tik Tok when someone posted false
allegations are taught by women in
advocacy groups to divorcing women to
steal kids from
fathers naturally that piqued my
curiosity and I was shocked so I said oh
my gosh that's terrifying I need to
expose this in a video the original
poster said the rabbit hole is going to
make you see this entire system in a new
horrifying way you and your father were
victims of the alienator and
courts which is uh something that I
didn't know if this was true or not uh
like I said my parents never even went
to court so I was curious about what he
meant by this it gets worse I said what
really how can I find more info on this
he goes on to say it's all a scam the
courts and lawyers get money from
dragging fathers for years through the
courts he said he went through this
exact thing this point I'm definitely
getting a little uneasy and I'm
definitely curious to learn more someone
else joined in said sadly this was my
experience too the vital spewed at me by
these Advocates who cared nothing about
the kids or the truth was unbelievable
naturally I wanted proof so I said do
you guys have any links or specific
groups I can look at and someone said
look up civil look up silver bullet
divorce alienation is part of the
strategy I've been terrified to talk
about it because there is a real threat
of jail
time I have interviewed so many guys
with this same story on and off camera
there are men that come up to me all of
the time and they just tell me their
life story they say
finally somebody is talking about
this and you'll have all these people
that just say we're just making this up
we're doomers this is so common
so
common children need
fathers and many times a man signing up
to get married is a death sentence and
until this
changes tradcon saying that the solution
is to take the god pill and pray this
was a Catholic
mother this was a a God will not save
you from the divorce
courts I am not saying that men
shouldn't get married every guy has to
pick for himself he has to look at the
benefits and the costs that's what men
have to do it's it's not my business to
tell men how to live their
lives but what irritates me is the
tradcons just waving away these concerns
like they're not real and saying men
buckle up and sign up
anyway I would go as far to say that
that is
irresponsible it is IR responsible to
push marriage without warning guys about
all of
this and then they say pearl you're just
a
Doomer you know what was a red pill for
me guys I started asking my Uber drivers
I just started like um I take Ubers a
lot so I just started asking guys like
their life story you know I'm a Chatty
Cathy you
know I had so many Uber drivers that
told me they were ubering because of a
divorce it is not uncommon I'm going to
keep going someone else jumped in and
said this is exactly how they do it the
courts are all well aware of the game
they profit from it the best interest of
the children is a running joke and I
know that's true so I decided to Google
Silver Bullet divorce and this is where
I got Disturbed I'm in the car driving
to the mountains and I'm Googling in the
car silver silver bullet
divorce I decided to go ahead and uh
record my screen knowing that I was
probably going to do a video on this and
I had heard the sil before which is when
a parent or child makes false
allegations of abuse usually sexual
abuse against the other parent but
Silver Bullet divorce I believe is
something a little bit different and I
had never heard of that H I have to take
a deep breath very shortly I came to
learn what that kind man on Tik Tok was
talking about when he said that I would
I was going to realize how the courts
had played a role in the alienation and
this website says many family law
attorneys are using the Silver Bullet
divorce tactics and it talks about
filing a PFA protection from abuse or a
child abuse claim it says the standard
of EV evidence is entirely too low in
domestic violence cases yes I know the
font here is really really small but
this is the website that really outlined
what exactly Silver Bullet divorce is
and I would love to read through this
with you guys oh my God it's what
happened in my case it's what my mom did
what her lawyer told her to do and then
what she decided to do without any
regard to her children it says if you're
headed to divorce Men Please read this
the Silver Bullet technique involves a
carefully contrived and set up false
accusation of domestic abuse or when
possible the provocation of a real
incident of domestic abuse those who
perpetrate the scam will make the charge
of domestic abuse no matter what their
victim does or fails to do in many cases
they close joint bank accounts make
doctor's appointments before they create
the incident it happens hundreds of
times every day this technique is being
taught by political activists whose pose
as women's victim Advocates it is a
means of gaining advantage in any
confrontation particularly
divorce it gives the complaining party
referred to as the victim immediate
exclusive custody to the house the
contents of the house and to the
children it gives the real victim
referred to as the defendant who here is
the targeted parent the responsibility
for all the bills while he is trying to
deal with suddenly becoming homeless
that's right he had to go live at his
parents
house the perpetrators call themselves
victims the real victims generally do
not have a clue what was done to them
darvo that's how they reverse the victim
and perpetrator they paint themselves to
the victim when they're really the
perpetrator over and over it says we see
the following interesting phenomenon and
here's where it got creepy and I started
to really get sick to myself stomach
number one a marriage has existed for
decades there was never a call to 911
never a policeman in the house never a
complaint to Family Court never a
complaint to the Department of Social
Services never a time when the wife left
the house to avoid
abuse check mark for me never once was
there anything like this
happening ever
before number two the wife goes to see a
divorce attorney for reasons known only
to
herself check number three within a few
weeks there is a call to
911 police in the house a complaint to
Family Court a complaint to the
Department of Social Services check on
the night of the alleged abuse it says
the wife leaves the house to avoid
abuse yep check remember I said she
brought us to my grandma's house my
grandma's house the next day she has her
husband thrown out of the house by the
court yeah exactly this is literally
what happened to my
dad this is exactly what happened to my
dad how terrible is this this is
deranged this is sick how sick and the
whole time I thought that he was the
abuser and rejected him when in fact he
was the freaking victim the whole time
the whole time she you did this on
purpose number four of course the
divorce attorney claims no involvement
in creating such a strange change in the
pattern of the marriage if the most
exalted love of your life ever becomes a
woman's scorn you could still see this
happen most of these women scorn
scenarios involve
wives I know it's not a gendered issue
I'm sure men have done this too the
Silver Bullet technique is a system of
stripping you of your property your
right to own a gun and your freedom it
can put you out of your home with no
access to your own money your children
or your possessions it can cause you
unlimited legal expenses it can turn
your family and friends against you the
Silver Bullet technique is being
implemented by a well organized network
of lawyers par legals advocacy groups
radical women groups prosecutors doctors
police and even judges the Silver Bullet
technique replaces the family unit with
the power of government it seems like
radical claims but I know it's not cuz
this is literally what happened to my
dad and subsequently to our relationship
it would never be the same after this
never after that I had to close my phone
and stay off of it for the remainder of
the day I was going back and forth in my
head about whether to even make this
video when I talk about more personal
things I seem to feel a sense of guilt
for even putting my mom on a negative
light but this is bigger than than my
story this is bigger than my mom my dad
this is the Playbook part of the
Playbook that people talk about when
they talk about how the stories are so
similar I don't know why there isn't
more training on how this is happening
how damaging this can be for not only
the
parent and the children but for their
relationship for potentially decades or
a
lifetime
so what I'm going to cut this
here what what did this Dad do
wrong he married a Catholic
woman maybe you're Christian maybe
you're Orthodox but he did the right
thing he got married to the mother of
his kids he didn't divorce he stayed
with
her and he was called an
abuser for a
Lifetime and guys there are so many kids
that never figure it
out there are so many kids I've
interviewed a thousand people and you
just start to notice
patterns like I'll interview someone
that that says they hate their dad right
and I would just ask him a couple
questions like oh how much time did you
spend with him when's the last time you
saw
him and many times many
times
they have not even spent enough time
with the dad in my opinion to really
conclude that he's a bad guy but when
the mother has been in the kids's ear
for a decade of their
life what conclusion do the kids come
to their mom says he's an abuser the mom
says he's evil so many kids have been
lied to and saying take the god pill
will not save you from Divorce Court it
will not save you from a scorned woman
and I used to guys I used to have a
similar opinion I used to say why don't
guys just I mean where I'm
from where I'm from people don't do that
I would just think well my friend's
parents were
married and then do you know what I I
realized oh [__] that friend didn't like
her dad I wonder if there was more to
that
story that you know acquaintance got
divorced I wonder what happened there
you don't know as a
kid and then the truth starts coming out
you hear more and more
stories so you know what is a trucker in
Philadelphia Ohio supposed to do about
the entire system men
adapt and women picked this women chose
this women chose to kick the men out of
the homes women didn't have to do
that so you know that's why I I don't
feel it's right to blame men for the way
they adapt and tweeting take the god
pill and crying about Le the Leonardo
DiCaprio of the world screwing in 22y
olds is isn't going to do
anything the only what what what happens
guys when you raise the price of
something without increasing the
value it's inflated we're in whole
inflation what what happens when you
raise the price of marriage the cost of
marriage without increasing the value of
it and then you increase the risk men
just naturally do cost benefit
analysises and The Jig Is Up
you know many men have seen something
happen to a friend of theirs they've
seen something happen to their dad their
grandpa many men are going to look at
the market and say I could could is it
better for me to be put in that position
like that guy or go be Leonardo
DiCaprio many men are gonna pick
Leonardo
Dicaprio and the only thing that I see
changing this I I think guys like Leo
are just going to do their thing you
know is you have to lower the risk of
marriage and kids and many people will
come in and say pearl why don't you why
don't you just tell guys to not get
married with the
state and I
wanna when you have a child it is 50%
your DNA you should have automatically
50% custody why do women get custody 90%
of the time that's wrong and many times
I can't even get tradcons to agree that
that's
wrong
so until women stop falsely accusing
men and stealing their children and
their
assets or the laws catch
up I I don't know what route you expect
men to go
down so you know I'm gonna give you guys
some incent incentives things that I
think could work now I'm not saying they
will work yeah bring back shaming I I
don't completely disagree
guys but I have never seen women fight
for anything harder than the right to be
hores I just have never seen
it so I
mean I get you know look at calendar
gate Kate gate on Twitter uh this is
just what women love to do we
good luck Jesus
um but in my
opinion until the laws evolve I don't
see traditionalism coming back because
it's always GNA be you can't have a
traditional marriage when it's always
when it's traditional until she [__]
until she decides
differently so things that I think could
help get married in the eyes of God it's
not marriage it's kids when you have
children she it it doesn't matter where
you're
at I mean you can maybe find your odd
State here or there but even with that
guys we have an entire culture that
automatically puts women as the victim
women are pedestalize women are told
they're so special awesome important and
innocent from the time we're
children so is that just the quick fix I
mean sure I mean it helps but okay
things that I think could actually be
could work in
20124 better than tweeting
take the god
pill
just I I I understand great tweets get
your likes but let's let's talk
real maybe
Solutions um if a man has a surrogacy
now this isn't moral this isn't me
saying this is right this is what you
should do uh technically that's the only
way he can have a kid and it be his okay
one two tax
incentives so you know cutting tax rates
significantly for men that have children
and women okay lowering the risk of
marriage automatic 5050
custody
um getting the government completely out
of marriage and child
custody demolishing child support I have
no idea how you would do that
but um I've also toyed with the idea of
suing child they call child maintenance
services
here don't know maybe okay abolishing
alimony uh mandatory DNA tests
okay false FSE um making it a crime to
falsely accuse somebody of grape
okay now are our politicians catching on
to this you know the
men the men running for office or they
saying you know what men we're gonna
we're gonna help you guys we're gonna
fix the problem we're gonna do it also
guys if you like this content please
consider send sending a cash app or
venmo we're currently
demonetized don't know why um and it
would be it would be very helpful okay
so oh
[__] let's talk about just the project
of uniting this country and right now we
have a major divide in this country and
at a certain point we're going to have
to look 360 Degrees across the board and
say all right we're all laying down arms
we're going to agree to be one nation
we're going to agree to disagree on the
issues where we disagree most Prof
profoundly to say that we are still
going to be bound by a common set of
principles As Americans take abortion
right this is one where they say this
going to divide the country to a
Breaking Point I've stood for policy and
that's a mistre to me I'm the only
Republican who has advocated for this I
think it's a winner politically but I
think it's also the right thing to do
they say okay you can't find common
ground in abortion how about this one
tell me we got three guys here at the
table let's talk from manto man on this
I think that if a woman brings a child
to T this is what you [__] up at you
[__] up cuz there three men and
you're saying you're having a
conversation about all women you should
be bringing the women to the table this
is why the [__] you talking about the
founding father is some [__] because
you got a white men trying to make a
bunch of diverse groups no no most women
here like what I'm about to say most men
don't you got two women right there ask
them let's we have actually and and and
we've had a convers I think I think I
think you may be worried about what I'm
about to say which is that I think if a
woman brings a child to term she should
be able to make the man financially
responsible for both her and the child
if she does it period and that should be
the law
land stop
sing Oh
My
why why should women be rewarded for
making poor
choices so I get to be paid to be a
single
mother great yeah incentivize single
motherhood more we need more
of and I like I like him but come
on so this is the Pol I mean I know he's
not running anymore
but this is what you guys tradcons you
guys are tweeting at me and asking if
I'm going to
church instead of I don't know calling
this out this stuff would get you closer
to what you
want this stuff would get you closer to
traditionalism but instead of I don't
know talking about this you spend two
days tweeting at me like I have any say
on the laws of the
land freaking Jesus that happens though
no it doesn't it doesn't happen today
not the not not to the scale I'm talking
about full fin it's you you do 50/50 you
got 40% for the man I'm talking about
100% so it's 2x over he's fully
responsible for the woman and fully
responsible for the child okay then give
him the
kid then give him the kid at that
okay why would I have to pay for a kid
that I don't even get to she has to
because her responsibility she took nine
months to actually bring the child to
term if it's confirmed with the genetic
paternity all right I hate to be this
person can we stop pretending like
getting pregnant and giving
birth is this special God like this they
they make it seem like it's like the
hardest thing on the planet now I know I
know my mom my mom had biologically
seven of us okay I'm not saying it's
easy but like you get to be taken care
of 18 years for nine
months am I am I is it crazy for me to
so right now today 40 years ago he has
full responsibility the child's 18
absolutely and full responsibility for
the woman during that time I don't think
that's bad I don't think it's bad
either
freaking because I think that part of
the criticism of Republicans is oh
you're just throwing women under the bus
I say let's actually that's I would say
yeah I mean I'm tired women just want
handouts yeah Fair criticism let's
actually take that seriously and say
we're all in this together if you
believe that un women would agree with
it okay yeah let's let's just pay women
to be single mothers let's let's just I
think most most women absolutely for the
child and for me most women would agree
with that right and that's not and
that's
not the guy over there is like I don't
know state of but but then men should
think about that on the front end that's
the whole point cuz women can't afford
that either that okay
but okay but then no he should be able
to sign off his rights during the
pregnancy if she can kill the kid that's
true fairness the whole this this gets
to the heart of the
abortion gets to the heart of the
abortion so
again it's giving men all of the
responsibility with none of the
authority saying is you think about that
on the front end exactly the whole point
remember when Young Thug was like yo if
you broke shouldn't be having baby and
then these women are stealing condoms
like I mean I'm not okay I'm not saying
like Okay you should be careful I'm with
it I'm with it
but you know and so these tradcons will
spend like two days tweeting at me
they're they're praying for me right
when okay go spend a day in Family Court
you want
traditionalism go go spend a day in
family court go actually talk to these
guys but none of these guys have any
idea what they're talking about they
don't
know or they're just pandering to the
female
audience
so
yeah um I'm sorry this is not I was
gonna do a Colin show but I have to go
to volleyball soon so I have to go um I
know I know I know I'm sorry guys but we
are going to do Colin show soon because
my curiosity is what now
I just I don't see any of this stuff
going
anywhere
so okay I'm sorry I knew I knew you guys
were gonna start complaining in the chat
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay but you know this is my question to
tradcons what is your plan to
incentivize men to
marry what's your real plan to lower the
risk of marriage and incentiv men to
marry other than tweeting at people to
pray as great of a plan as that is and
telling women to put their clothes on
Good
Luck what what is your
plan
okay you know and stop tweeting at me
about my church am I praying it's just
annoying I'm like
um
it's just it's like they argue like
women a lot of them anyways let me know
what you guys think maybe I'm wrong but
I wanted to clarify I wanted to clarify
my opinions on this stuff um let me know
what you think in the
comments also guys um feel free to send
a cash up or a venmo as we are
demonetized and you know really that's
the only way we're going right now so
like please stop booing I got to go all
right like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel I love you guys